-We met when you started "SNL.
We overlapped very briefly
-I know you didn't know
I was going to say this.
When I first met Seth,
first of all,
the first thing I thought --
first when I met Colin,
I was like, "This is the perfect
white-man machine."
[ Laughter ]
And then when I met Seth,
I was like, "Wow!
He's like the next president."
[ Laughter ]
"He's so beautiful."
-Oh, my God.
Oh, you're very kind.
-I was like, "These white me
around here are so beautiful."
-Thank you.
[ Laughter ]
-His steel blue -- I was like,
yeah, whatever, dude.
But let me say
something about Seth.
Seth was the first person that
was telling Lorne, like,
"Yo, she funny, like, she funny.
If you ain't going to have her
I'll take her. Like, she's mine.
Like, she's not leaving
this building."
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And the thing -- we talke
about it before.
The really funny thing was whe
you started on the show,
when the season started,
I think --
No, maybe it started
at the beginning.
But you had
the smallest desk of anybody
-Oh, I had the glass desk.
But I didn't even care
because I was in the corner.
And I was like, we play baseball
every Saturday.
I don't care.
I was always scared I was goin
to bump my knee and crack
the desk and I was
going to bleed to death.
-Do you remember where you wer
when you found out
you joined the cast?
-Yes. Ha!
[ Laughter ]
Okay. Okay.
So, first of all, I was cocky.
Like, where I was, I was like,
you know, ghetto fabulous.
Like, I was at
the top of my game.
When I walk in the room, I rep
You know, and I have respect
You know what I'm saying?
So when they called me for this,
I was like,
"I'm going to go show them
how dope I am,
and I'm going to
walk out the room."
You know what I'm saying?
But they made me want it.
I really wanted it after tha
whole week of being here,
watching them do the stage
and watching the writers,
and then watching the band
I was like, "I want this."
Like, "Ooh, I want this so bad."
And I was driving
to get my nails done
over there on
Adams and Crenshaw,
and it's a bomb nail shop. Yep
Stop and see Nikki.
She does do the bomb eyelashes
-Oh, yeah,
that's a very good one.
-It's a good one, right? Okay.
Anyway.
[ Laughter ]
So I pulled in and I kept seeing
my phone ring, 212.
So I thought it was just
somebody calling going,
"Yeah, we saw her but we'r
going to go with somebody else."
That's what I thought
that call was.
But it kept ringing
and it kept ringing.
And I was like, I pulled in,
parked, and I was like, "Hello?"
It was like, "Yeah,
Lorne Michaels for you."
And I was like, "Oh, right her
in the parking lot?
Yeah, let's do this."
He was like, "Yeah, Leslie,
want you to come out,"
and he was like, "I want you t
come out and be a writer."
I was like, "Oh, Lorne, you know
I'm not no writer.
I'm a performer. I belong
in front of the camera."
And he was like,
"I know what you are,
but I need you here so I can see
exactly what to do with you.
I don't know what to do with
you. Just come."
So I was like, "Yeah."
You know, I tried to play,
"Yeah, alright, you know."
[ Laughter ]
"That's cool.
You know what I'm saying.
I'll see -- I'll see you
in a minute."
[ Laughter ]
Then I hung up the phone.
I jumped out,
and I have an Altima.
I had a beautiful
burgundy Altima,
and I jumped out and I ran
around the whole
parking lot, going...
[ Screaming ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my God.
The security guard was like --
The security guard
knew who I was.
He was like, "What's wrong
What's happened?
Has something happened?
And I was like, "I got 'SNL'
I got 'SNL'!
He was like, "What is that
Is that a disease?!
Is it a disease?!"
-Well, it all worked out, an
congrats again on the special.
Always so fun to have you here
Leslie. Leslie Jones.